this is the newest member of the saeed
family
yusuf is just two weeks old his parents
are smitten
but his entry into the world didn't go
as it should his dad wasn't even allowed
to be there
at about nine o'clock when the baby was
born i
heard heard his cry it was very short
and i hadn't realized it at the time so
i only realized about 20 minutes later
when my wife
um picked up the phone and told me that
baby was born
the official covert guidelines say that
partners are allowed to be present
throughout labour
we'll tell that to the saeeds it was
ripped cursed where we expressed where i
gave birth to my
third kid when you are like
having such a hard time you want someone
to be with you
at that time and unfortunately it didn't
happen
like my husband wasn't there my
understanding is that most hospitals
will let them in for
some of the labor at least but that
didn't happen to you yeah did
did allow uh only during the labor par
like if you are in labor war then they
allow your partner to be there with you
but unfortunately there was no space in
the labor world and i was there in the
mulberry wall
and they said it is against the protocol
they can't let
my husband come in so
during whole time i was alone yeah and
obviously
i'm giving birth is such a great thing
yeah it's it's a difficult thing to go
through initially i asked them for
like epidural that was my plan and
they said okay they will do something
about that but
then um they had something else in their
minds
and they didn't give me epidural and
they said okay we can give you a die
more often instead
and they went to take diamorphine it
literally took them one hour
and no one came back and in that one
hour
i delivered my baby on my own and there
was no one by my side
and it was it was
really difficult for me and
i can't even express in words how
painful it was
and it was really miserable
do you feel that with covert 19 with
coronavirus
it's almost like some hospitals have
swung too far they're not thinking about
the other patients that they need to
look after yeah
partner sport is
is is really
you know it's really important
and they should they should care
even they should care more about the
patient
but i think they are more stressful
because of understaffing
because of i don't know what kind either
they are
getting good budget for their hospitals
or not but
they are understaffed i could see there
whips cross hospital are now looking
into the complaint a spokesperson for
bart's health nhs trust which manages
the hospital said
we're deeply sorry to hear about the
concerns raised by rohan syed
and iram said regarding the care
received during the birth of their child
and have offered to meet the family to
discuss their concerns
to keep patient staff and visitors safe
during the pandemic we've had to
restrict families visiting our hospital
but an exception has been made so that
partners can attend 12 and 20-week scans
as well as throughout labour and birth
whips cross isn't the only hospital to
restrict visitors to maternity services
during the pandemic
in september new guidance was issued
asking trust to relax visiting
restrictions
so partners can attend maternity units
for appointments and births
but it seems the advice is being applied
inconsistently
data compiled by the guardian last month
showed only 23 percent of trusts are
allowing partners to attend the whole
labor
and half of women are having to attend
scan appointments alone
since i started looking into this issue
i've been really moved by some of the
stories i've heard
women having to give birth alone but
also the impact that covert has had on
miscarriages
and stillbirths and scan appointments
too when a pregnancy goes smoothly
it might not be a big deal if a partner
can't come along to a scan appointment
but when things go wrong forcing women
to hear
very bad news on their own without a
handle hold
that there's no heartbeat or that their
baby is very sick and
the very worst decisions have to be made
well that feels very cruel
the baby lost charity tommy's has
reported an 88
increase to their helpline since the
start of lockdown this
decision to ban partners for temporarily
banned partners
um from scans is done by a trust by
trust basis so some trusts
might feel that you know that that the
time has now come that they're allowing
partners to come back into the scan room
and in my london trust we are we are
doing that for the 12-week scan which is
really great for those families
but i think what people find hard is
knowing that you know in the in the
trust over the way
where they're not having care women can
have their partners with them
and in their own trust they might still
be um not able to do
that now politicians are calling for
change
i'm disappointed that we haven't sorted
this problem out
and the heart of this issue is not just
the obvious thing that this is
the most special moment in your life and
you want to have your your loved one
with you it's also sadly a moment where
things can go wrong
and you can have a stillbirth you can
have sadly a baby who's
born and doesn't make it and that is
really a moment when you have to have
a loved one with you and we on the
select committee heard some very
harrowing stories the guidance obviously
has changed to try and get trust to find
a way of introducing partners to
the appointments and to the birth the
whole of the birth but it feels like a
bit of a postcode lottery
well i think that's right and the reason
why it's taken longer is because
hospitals
absolutely rightly are focused on
infection prevention
and we know that about seventy percent
of the people with covid have no
symptoms at all but there's a very
simple solution
which is just to say whoever your
significant other is
um they should get a test and once
they've tested negative
they can then accompany the mother at
all stages of the pregnancy and that's
what we need to sort out are you worried
that some trust might be tightening the
rules again well i think
trusts will have to tighten rules as the
infection rates
start to go up really around the whole
country
would you support the idea of another
national lockdown well i i'm always in
favor of
taking decisive action earlier
i think we did lock down too late in the
first time
i think it's a very finely balanced
judgment on this occasion because you do
have some parts of the country with
relatively low
infection rates and i think i'd be
guided by what the scientists are saying
rising covered cases could mean renewed
restrictions
liverpool women's hospital has
temporarily stopped antenatal and
postnatal visits
half of nhs trusts say they would
consider tightening the rules
in the event of rising rates the
situation could get worse
before it gets better